with the critically-acclaimed 10 worst
animated moments of Dragon Ball super
battle of gods ark in the books it seems
only fitting I take on the next arc in
the series now before fiery pitchforks
are thrown at my person please know that
this is made in a light-hearted manner
for fun I love this series and just
because someone criticizes something
doesn't mean that they are and I despise
these terms being a hater or hating to
say I am such for sharing my pins about
a show that I love is just ridiculous
tons of youtubers have made so many
videos discussing the animation of super
in such a serious way so let's have some
fun with this one and laugh at some
funny pictures instead oh my god that's
rancid make it stop please make it stop
oh ok here we go I present to you the 10
worst animated moments of Dragon Ball
super resurrection of F Ark the show is
[ __ ] I'm kidding
number 10 Goku's chubby bunny admittedly
this is a small gripe perhaps this
picking this is indicative of a
perfectly animated Ark but seriously
when I make these lists I don't go
through each episode frame by frame that
would be unfair i watch it through once
picking out moments that stand out to me
and this definitely stood out to me the
closing moments of the battle between
Goku and Frieza had Goku looking like he
had a mouthful of sweets I've noticed it
before at different times in the series
but at a pivotal moment like this it's
kind of hard to forgive then again a
mouthful of food isn't exactly out of
Goku's character either huh let I'll
allow it
number none GN Jin hun guys what the
hell is happening
first Crillon now Tian dude at one point
look more small than Goku's cheeks a man
who once had boulders for shoulders
seeing him in this state is almost
worrying now he kind of looks like a
middle evolution from chiaotzu Tian
[ __ ]
I shall name him Chen su and none shall
rival him number 8
Goku's weird hand if you guys thought we
were gonna have a list void of any hand
slip-ups then you were mistaken now I
know people fight or play sports ball
end up damaging their hands causing them
to look less than normal but this is
just ridiculous if you can contort your
hand to look like this I'll renounce my
statements and call this the best moment
you have my word
number 7 Frieza blows up planet
one actually really annoyed me not just
because it's not animated well for more
so because up until this point the arc
was pretty much solid take this moment
out in episodes 15 through 22 would be
perfectly fine it had a nice Street
going in fact by the time I got to
episode 23 I was facing the very real
possibility I'm not having any material
for this video
episode 19 however provided us with this
we've seen Frieza as well as others
destroy planets
beerus had done in a bunch just a few
episodes prior it happens all the time
point is we know that this isn't what a
world eradicating explosion looks like
it's like coming face-to-face with an
enormous intimidating beast then
suddenly it shits itself sort of a
letdown if you ask me especially since
they've done this so many times before
but I shan't dwell on it
it's a minor blemish on what was a
really good streak for super number 6
Goku and Frieza head clashes as soon as
this fight begins you just know
something is off coming off the back of
the resurrection of that movie there is
a lack of weight to everything that's
happening and I don't mean that in the
emotional investment or a consequent
sorta way I mean the characters don't
look like they have any weight with
their punches this head-on-head
collision is a prime example of what I
mean there is no give or change to any
parent of the characters and this is
because it's just one drawing which they
have refused to alter and is moved
across the screen through tweening no
new drawings means it looks phony as
hell people notice the difference
between this and this one looks like it
makes contact and the other doesn't it
might not bother some people but it
really bothered me
number 5 [ __ ] fighting huh if you think
that I anime about punching and kicking
would at the very least have we'll
orchestrated fight scenes well this
little nugget taken directly out of
episode 24 we see base form goto going
toe to toe what the [ __ ] is even
happening oh look he did the childish I
poke thing and and look it's it's
raining cherries good job the cheetah
look I got a little bit more to talk
about on the subject but I'm gonna touch
on it in a little later just know
there's gonna be a whole lot more of
this stuff going on number 4 freezes
punch - Goku does nothing
I don't know about you guys but I
thought the resurrection of F movie was
much better than I anticipated it to be
usually when a villain returns for one
last hurrah it's forced and well pretty
shitty but that story had just enough
twists and turns to keep me invested
throughout and have had some Goku's most
badass moments ever this was my favorite
scene and he did bloom Bruce Lee hands
punch think it's so [ __ ] awesome in
the series this moment while trying to
accomplish the same thing fell extremely
flat again it all boils down to those
punches not feeling like they have any
weight behind them at all it looks like
a couple of 2d images dancing around in
separate planes of existence unable to
touch one another animation is an
illusion and this fails miserably in
short they probably could have benefited
from just copying and pasting the stuff
from the movie probably would have had
less backlash number three hugglemas
death
I've heard this scene being praised
online and holy [ __ ] if I hear any of
you are praising this scene
I will [ __ ] find you and I will
politely argue my point to you the
cheetah has had moments like this before
moments that showcase which he is
ruthless so we've seen it before nappa
Kui did Ori Zarb on most of the ginyu
foot well I guess all the can you force
because Takuma is game you can you is
now Tagum ah line one is think'll Finkle
is Einhorn Einhorn is a man
oh my god in this he just raises his arm
and it wasn't even fast it was slow as
[ __ ] like an elderly woman hailing a
[ __ ] cab there was nothing to this it
was just a nothing scene it just left me
scratching my head thinking wow tug of
his a [ __ ] and not that Vegeta was a
badass which is what I think they were
trying to go for I mean let's be real
tog him I had like a century to move
there this is a guy who was facing
freezer training with him being his
punching bag for four months in a row
and all of a sudden what I'm supposed to
believe that he's just paralyzed with
fear because that's the only thing that
enters the realm of being a rational
thought here I don't know Vegeta just
[ __ ] number two go up power up whoa
looks like the Gohan Express is pulling
into the station for another outstanding
Gohan moment and boy that Gohan sure is
standing outside looking about as
intimidating as a wheelchair-bound puppy
that's dead goannas [ __ ] the orange key
in favor of this little green number
that makes him look like just B biggest
Eastern European scumbag the one saving
grace for this scene is that I know this
is the prime location for a team four
star dodge joke who needs this when we
have this monstrosity go on don't stop
changing bro number one Goku vs Frieza
to some this might be a bit of a cop-out
but as a dragon ball fight this for me
ranks among the worst and I'm sure many
of you will agree well it did have brief
moments of brilliance
it was overshadowed by extremely dull
and unimaginative combat choreography it
honestly felt as though a kid's
storyboard this fight scenes of energy
blasts are a dime a dozen featuring in
episodes 24 25 26 and the final 127 each
one fitting like filler and 90% of it
looks like this motion tweens are my pet
peeve when it comes to animation instead
of drawing new frames they just drag the
same illustration across the screen they
also can downsize it to make it look
like it's getting further away only
problem is that it looks like [ __ ]
ass when it's done like this
firstly I found this fight frustrating
to watch as someone who stands behind
what super did in the battle of gods
fight and beerus i have to say this one
is hard to justify the entire fight
feels like they were just going through
the motions waiting for the act to end
which is a shame because this arc had me
in stitches laughing it's such a funny
arc that scene where goku asked mr. sane
to punch him is now one of my favorite
moments in all of Dragonball I rarely
can say that the best part of a
Dragonball story is the filler but damn
this was [ __ ] amazing
Goku training with Vegeta all that great
comedy with Goku and the hijinks with
Jocko made this filler a joy to watch so
while 90% of this list is comprised of
four bad episodes
I thought nine from this act were golden
don't believe me check it out for
yourself just make sure to fast forward
the Frieza part I've been totally not
mark and this has been the 10 worst
animated moments of Dragon Ball super as
a resurrection of f arc thank you so
much for watching